- For a season finale? It
feels like a season finale.
(Katie screams)
- Why?
- My game plan is to have some fun,
and hopefully do better than Katie.
- I feel bad for Jasmine. (laughs)
- Open the door, open the
door. Cut, cut, cut, cut, cut.
(laughs)
(beep)
- Hi, I'm Mimo.
- And I'm Kelly.
- And we are back with another episode
of Lost In Translation,
and I cannot miss an opportunity
to mess with my friends.
- Today, we're having Katie
and Jasmine go head to head
with no help from each other
to see how each of them
translate the same recipe.
- Maybe separating them this
time will be a good idea,
since it didn't go well last time.
- Probably.
- Oh, we made something
that's so different.
- If this is your first time joining us,
we put a recipe through Google Translate.
We go from English to
Urdo to Thai to Kamai,
and many, many more times,
and then back to English
to get a hilariously translated recipe.
- Let's go mess with our friends.
- Let's do it.
(cheery music plays)
- Back from vacation
and ready to torture me?
- I am so ready.
- Ready?
- Uh, no. (laughs)
You just ran away. (laughs)
- Taste of the Stomach.
(Jasmine and Katie laugh)
- It sounds delicious.
- That doesn't sound that great. (laughs)
Let's do it.
- Let's begin.
Step number one.
- [Both] Connect and
crushed one yellow evil.
- One yellow evil? Connect and crush?
(Mimo and Kelly laugh)
- Right now, I'm thinking one yellow evil
could be one yellow onion.
- Right off the bat,
I'm seeing bananas here.
I'm seeing squash.
- Or a yellow squash.
- Is there anything in the freezer?
There's Tortito's pizza rolls. (laughs)
This is a nightmare of yellow. (all laugh)
(Kelly sighs)
- Wanna do some word association?
- No, I don't. I'm not good
at word association. (laughs)
Jasmine's so good.
She's like, "Eat, water,
strawberry, strawberry.
Cold, chill. Chill, spoon, ice, metal."
Like, she's just...
- Squash, press. Press, smash.
Smash, kill. Kill, evil.
- I'm gonna use one of
my hints at the very top,
'cause I feel like this is so important.
- Evil things make you cry.
- Onions...
Onions, onions. (all laugh)
I wasn't even thinking...
I don't think Jaz is gonna
use her clue on step one.
- I think it's onion.
I think connect and crush is
peel and dice, or chop. (ding)
Let's just hope I'm making
the right decision here.
My game plan is to have some fun.
- She has more confidence, you
know? She's been doing this.
- And hopefully do better than Katie.
But if not, it's okay. Whatever.
- Step two.
- Squeeze one pound squash,
eat well and cut well.
- Leave me alone? (laughs)
We've got squash. Squash
could be potatoes. (laughs)
- I think I'm gonna do
potatoes. I'm committing.
I'm a little sad that Katie's
not here to bully me, too.
- Leave me alone.
(Katie humming)
I'm gonna do potatoes.
I'm gonna do Yukon golds,
because I like them. (ding)
I thought about the fingerling,
but they're kinda harder to peel,
and I think I'm gonna need to peel
if I'm gonna be squeezing, (ping)
though I do like skin.
- Which potato to do? (ping)
I'm gonna go with russet. (buzzer sounds)
Potatoes are nice and rinsed,
and now I'm gonna peel them. (ding)
Leave me alone means
set to the side. (ding)
- I think squeezing is hash browns.
Like, I feel like we're making
a fritter, which... (ping)
I don't know.
I'm just gonna quickly
keep peeling these, (ding)
and then we're shredding
them. (buzzer sounds)
I'm going to squeeze one
pound squash, (buzzer sounds)
and I hope that squash
is not actually squash.
Gorgeous, gorgeous. (laughs)
- Step three.
- Put two cups chestnut water
in a hot pan until softened.
You reduced the temperature.
I did nothing of the sort. (laughs)
- [Both] Chestnut water?
- I think that's, like,
telling me to put something in a hot pan,
bring it up to a boil, and
then reduce to a simmer.
What it is, I have no idea. (laughs)
There's so many oils over here,
I don't wanna look. (ping)
- Maybe I should use a hint?
I'd like to use a hint.
- Water doesn't mix well with...
- Oil? (ping)
Chestnut water is canola oil? (ping)
- Are these chestnut waters?
They're full of water, and they're, like,
little nuts on the vine. (ping)
(Katie laughs)
- Peanut oil, nice. Let's do that.
- I think that these are
chestnut waters. (buzzer sounds)
I am gonna measure out two cups.
I actually love to make,
like, a quick tomato jam.
Does anyone do that? (crickets chirp)
I'm gonna pretend I'm making
tomato jam right now. (laughs)
I feel like there's no
oil or anything in here.
But it doesn't say, like, put
two cups water in a hot pan...
It doesn't say anything about oil. (ping)
- Now I'm adding two cups of
chestnut water into my pot,
which is peanut oil. (buzzer sounds)
At least, I think it is.
Step number four. (ping)
Add oil in the pizza.
- Five to seven minutes
until salty and soft.
Wait, but I softened something,
and now something's
becoming salty and soft?
No. Is that the pizza?
Wow, wow. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
- Add oil in the pizza.
Maybe my pizza is potato.
Dude, pizza rolls? This is a good day.
- I'm having a nervous breakdown. (laughs)
- I feel like onions could go in here
for five to seven minutes.
I'm gonna add the onions in. (ding)
I'm gonna let that go for
five to seven minutes,
until they're salty and soft.
I think salty and soft is
soft and browned? (ping)
My onion look salty and soft,
so I am just going to remove them
and put them onto this paper towel here.
- I think my sauce here is the pizza,
so I'm gonna add some oil, (buzzer sounds)
and then I'm gonna add some salt,
because it says let it
get salty and soft. (ding)
I'm gonna mix all my tomatoes together.
This is not right. (laughs)
But it's very much, like, how
I make a quick tomato jam.
(Mimo laughs)
- We're back to the tomato
jam. (Kelly and Mimo laugh)
- [Katie] I'm committed to these tomatoes,
and we're gonna move forward,
and I'm happy about it. (ping)
- Step number five.
- Fruit should not be eaten
and stored while using fat.
(Kelly laughs)
- You guys are so mean.
Even Katie's not this mean.
(all laugh)
- This is the fruit, 'cause
the tomato is a fruit.
And they're, like, little nuts.
And I think that I'm gonna set this aside,
and I don't think it
wants me to eat it yet.
- Don't eat it yet? (Kelly laughs)
- I'm gonna let it reduce,
and I'm gonna set it off to the side.
That's kind of a very pretty color.
- Set the onions to the side for now.
Also leave the oil, 'cause
we might need some onion oil.
I guess. (ping)
So I'm just gonna set that
to the side for now. (ding)
Step number six.
- Cut the six whites into
cubes. Add some isotopes.
Was I this mean to you? (laughs)
- I feel like this step's easy. Yeah.
- Six whites is six egg whites into cubes.
Cut, cut, peel...
Cut the three... (Kelly and Mimo laugh)
- Isotopes. What are isotopes?
Does that have to do with salt
or crystallization? (ping)
- Cut the...
Three. Cut the potatoes into
six cubes, and salt them.
I will cut my potatoes into
six cubes. (buzzer sounds)
I'm gonna add some isotopes. (ding)
I just feel like something's missing,
so I'm gonna use my last hint.
- What comes first? The chicken or the...
- Egg.
I am just going to crack six
eggs into this bowl. (ding)
- I'm gonna look in the fridge.
There's pepperoni and tofu.
There's eggs. Crack.
Crack six white eggs.
Put six eggs in a bowl, and add some salt.
I'm at 1,000.
(Kelly and Mimo cheer)
- Step number seven.
- Tuck in sweet potatoes and
onions, and wait five minutes.
- I think...
Oh.
- I've got onions. I've
got sweet potatoes.
Tuck them in. Put them together?
- I'm gonna have to cut
these into smaller pieces,
and then combine everything with the eggs.
I don't understand why I
need to wait five minutes
to fold everything into
the eggs, but sure. (ping)
- I'm gonna put my
potatoes in my eggs. (ding)
I have so much fear,
because this is is really no turning back.
This is so many onions. (ding)
Like, I don't know if I want
that many onions in this dish.
- Now I'm gonna add in my
chopped potatoes, (ding)
my onions. (ding)
I am so curious as to where
Katie is in this step.
She's probably screaming. (laughs)
(Katie screams)
Why? (laughs)
Next up.
- Place three tablespoons of
canned butter on a large plate.
Can, jar? Butter, oil?
Jarred oil? (laughs)
- I think let's heat up
three tablespoons of butter
on a hot plate.
- It could definitely be butter.
Ghee? Ghee.
It could be ghee.
- I saw ghee over there,
so it could be ghee instead of butter.
- On a large plate? On a pan?
- Canned butter? (two pings)
I like butter. Ghee is good.
- I think I'm gonna do
ghee. (buzzer sounds)
I think canned butter is
clarified butter, (buzzer sounds)
AKA ghee, and my large
plate is my large pan.
While that's heating up, I'm
gonna move on to the next step.
- All right, next step.
- Step number nine.
Animals sizzle for one minute.
- [Both] Three to five?
- Is it my potato mixture?
- I think this is my
animal. Or is animal a meat?
Oh no.
I think this is all a
ruse. Should I use my hint?
Yeah, I guess I'll use my hint.
- You were on the right path
when you thought egg was animal.
- So this was a terrible
time to use my hint. (laughs)
- Right.
- Oh, sizzle on high for a minute,
and then reduce it for three to five.
Oh. (laughs)
- My gut tells me it's this.
All right, I'm gonna add
this in there. (ding)
I'm gonna let that sit for three to five.
- I'm gonna add my animal. (ding)
It's a little sizzle.
This is beautiful,
except for my chunky onion. (Kelly laughs)
so I'm gonna let this sizzle
for one minute on high,
and then I'm gonna reduce the heat,
and let it cook for about
three to five minutes. (ding)
I am seeing some of the
egg cook along the edges.
I feel like I can move
on to the next step.
- Can I read the next step?
- Step 10.
Cover, cover, cover, cover.
(Kelly and Mimo laughs)
- And fill with good bread.
- Cover, cover, cover,
cover? Okay, okay, okay.
- Cover? Cover this?
- There's breadcrumbs. (ping)
- Good bread, breadcrumbs. (ping)
- Okay, what I don't see is a
top big enough to cover this.
None of them are big enough,
which means they never
anticipating me covering it. (ping)
- I mean, I can cover it. (ding)
- Maybe I used the wrong pan. (laughs)
Maybe cover is, like, flip it.
Flip it, flip it, flip
it, flip it, flip it.
- Fill with good steam.
Let it steam up. (ping)
Yes, that's what I'm gonna do.
- I do have tomatoes, so I could, like,
cover it with the tomatoes.
I'm gonna cover, cover with my tomato jam.
I think fill with good
bread is flip it, (ding)
so here we go.
Oh my God, oh my God. Open
the door, open the door.
Cut.
(beep)
Everything's all right. The
building didn't catch on fire.
That was an epic flip. I'm
gonna flip this back in. (ding)
This is a mess.
Oh no, my tomatoes.
- Step 11.
- Put the turtle in a deep bowl
and cook for three to five minutes.
- [Both] What?
- Like, a deep dish?
- Pie dish?
- I'm gonna let it cook on this side
for three to five minutes,
and I'm not gonna overthink it. (ding)
- My gut says to finish cooking this,
and then transfer it into
this pie dish. (buzzer sounds)
And then broil for three to five minutes.
- [Kelly] Her face.
- You can't tell me that's wrong. (ping)
(buzzer sounds)
Step number 12.
Click on the small line
to complete the egg.
- As the water rises, so does
the speed. (Kelly laughs)
- That makes absolutely no sense.
- Is it, like, a haiku? (laughs)
- [Jasmine] My egg is complete.
I think I might need to skip that step.
- I think it's, like, take your spatula,
go around to make sure it's
not sticking. (buzzer sounds)
The water is rising. It's
rising off the pan. (laughs)
- I feel like I already did this,
so I'm gonna move on to the
next step. (buzzer sounds)
Step number 13.
- Retire Alaska from the oven.
I think that means remove
from the pan onto a plate.
Oh my God, all my egg. (laughs)
That's gonna be a garnish.
(Kelly and Mimo laugh)
I can't wait to see what
Jasmine made. (laughs)
- I'm pretty sure that meant
to remove this from the oven,
which I've already done, (buzzer sounds)
so I'm gonna move on to
the last and final step.
- Last step.
- Step number 14.
- [Both] Stop for about
10 minutes before pruning.
- I would assume that's, like,
let it rest for 10 minutes.
Like, let it cool for 10 minutes
before you eat this. (ding)
- So I'm gonna let this
rest for 10 minutes
before enjoying. (ding)
- I can't wait to see what Jasmine does.
I'm not excited to show
her what I did. (laughs)
- Let's bring them in.
- Let's do it.
- Yay.
(Jasmine and Katie laugh)
- [Katie] Kelly and Mimo are tough.
- [Jasmine] They are.
- We were helpful.
- Yeah.
- All right, bring them in.
- [Both] Oh.
- [Jasmine] They're so similar.
- [Katie] And yet so different. (laughs)
- [Jasmine] You added tomatoes. (laughs)
- Okay, we're ready for the real one.
- Three, two, one.
- [Both] Oh.
- So what is this dish called?
- [Mimo] It is called tortilla espanola,
and it's from Spain.
- [Katie] Ooh.
- [Jasmine] Wow.
- [Mimo] It's a Spanish omelet
with onions and potatoes.
- Let's try yours first.
- Okay.
- And then we'll try mine,
and then the real thing.
- Sounds good. Cheers.
- [Jasmine] I love the tomatoes.
- I don't need another
bite of mine. (laughs)
You know, I make a tomato
jam. I was telling them.
- Oh my God. (laughs)
- [Jasmine] Cheers.
- [Katie] It's good.
It's better than mine.
- [Both] Cheers.
- That's what's up. (laughs)
I feel so bad that that's so
much better than ours. (laughs)
The thinly sliced onion and the seasoning.
This is much better.
- Honestly though, I don't
feel like we were too off.
- No.
- Not at all.
- This was the hardest
recipe we've ever gotten.
- What a fun way to end the season.
- I love you.
- Yeah.
Thank you guys so much for
watching. This was so much fun.
- So much fun.
Thanks so much for your love and support,
and we will see you next time.
- Bye.
- Yeah.
(beep)
- You wore an apron.
- My shirt was see through.
(laughs)
Look how oily my paper is,
by the way. Can you see that?
- Lint made me cry.
I always feel like Jasmine's like,
"I need to get a bigger bowl."
- I feel like I could've
gone with the smaller pot.
- Why am I blinking? (laughs)
- Crazy. Crazy, crazy.
- Have you seen that? (laughs)
Crazy. (both laugh)
- I need a stretch break.
- Do we not go down the line?
- Sorry, I hit you.
- Let me tell you a little bit more
about my tomato jam. (laughs)
- [Mimo] No. (laughs)
(fanfare music plays)